obviously we're here at gamescom to
celebrate the games but a big part of
going to conventions is that there's a
ton of merch that's available to buy
tamar is very busy putting out fires at
this year's show so he doesn't have time
to go shopping he's given me and dave 30
euros each from his own pocket
so that we can buy him some gamescom tat
the best tat wins his eternal respect
ah there you are it's time to get up and
go bargain hunting
all right 30 euros can't see me get much
of this
we'll give it a go in order to buy for
tomorrow i have to think like tomorrow
so he likes
cats he likes anime and he likes
zarya from overwatch um
[Music]
i'm sure at least one of those things
will be here
i feel like overwatch might be too
obvious for tam
i think i'm just going to go around and
want to buy stuff from me at this point
get a pornhub t-shirt he'd love that
custom t-shirt
[Music]
it's a good idea but it's all in german
so i don't think i can do that
the the perfect one would be a
sue my hair academia body pillow i don't
know if they're gonna have that
and then again body pillow shop over
there
so let's go to the body pillow shop it's
basically like a disney infinity in
skylanders graveyard
which is actually quite sad but
i've seen something that i know tam will
really enjoy
[Music]
it just doesn't get better because
it's a woman looking at me and she
caught me looking at the body pillows
and i feel very uncomfortable
i feel like one to a winner here lads
do you have any my hero academia stuff
my hero academia no okay
which is mortimer oh look at all those
memes
[Music]
it's time to do do do
[Music]
there's there's a character in one piece
that's a skeleton man
know he likes him
[Music]
oh that's 35 euros
could actually get him a death note i
know he's always wanted one
that's actually that's that's good
oh it's not tight it's good it's good he
would like
it and also i'd like it have we been
here before
people keep looking at me when i look at
the body pillows
it's not for me i've already got one
uh number 16
i really need to do so i need to believe
in the heart of the cards
i've lost the anime shop
here is that one
excuse me for him
might be enough to win don't know what
lucy's got
[Music]
so lucy and i have spent our 30 euros we
brought tom a gift
because he's been working nice and hard
obviously
the best beer tat is going to win yeah
sam's favorite gift lucifer
so i'm going to get some gifts so i got
you many things
okay this is smart i like this okay so
first of all
you have a death note that's actually a
notepad
but inside they actually have like the
names and everything
from the anime and the manga pandering
pandering
i like it okay well also i love death
note
i got this nicholas cage memes
not a million memes did some real
pandering here lads
um that is going right on my laptop yeah
and then i got the
this is good but you're losing some
points why because there's too many
things that you like
best pokemon i know it's getting garbage
but they didn't have that but i like
something
and then maybe
a one punch man i know whoever wins this
i'm glad the tab just wins yeah
i'm so happy right now my pikachu is
moving
um and then finally something there's
more
one more this you actually guessed what
this was earlier and it made me die a
little bit inside because you went oh i
hope it's not a bloody fidget spinner
i think i saw one of them as well look
at that
you got this all within 30 yeah you have
a change
a euro change a batman fidget spinner
put it on put it on yeah mate
wow i guess i'm so happy right now i
guess like you've got another
you've got more gifts coming so i've
i've already one gift okay one gift
but it's something i thought very hard
about okay and it's something that
you've told me about before
all right and something that you've
shared with me
so i'm from sportsbreak that's later
okay so i've got you is the finest brook
statue
oh my god what he's he's smashing a
guitar on the floor
holy [ __ ] this is incredible you
told me about it told me about brooke a
lot
[Laughter]
it was it was next to the one-piece
statue that you have already have on
your desk
brooke is the best one-piece character
let me explain to you why all right let
me tell you about that one
that's before and he just appears on his
ghost ship
and he loves to eat and drink even
though he can't eat and drink he just
goes through
do i have to actually crown one of them
as a winner yeah you gotta go full simon
cowell oh you gotta decide which of your
acts to send home
i think you both exceeded expectations
wow
to be honest i was going for tats that's
like actual good game
legit good safety i'm gonna have to
throw something away to pack this
and i'm gonna do it so i got loads of
loads in my suitcase
you've both done exceptionally well you
both pandered to me
in a way that i've never been pandered
this is better than any birthday gift
i've
ever gotten including the ones that you
got me like me weeks ago
but i'm gonna have to give it
i'm gonna have to give it specifically
to this
just to the eye mask i love this figure
it's an incredible figure
i'm gonna give it to lucy for this is
that is that literally just because
there's loads of light pollution in your
room right now
exactly there's a man who appears every
morning
wearing nothing at my airbnb and it's
it's when the sun appears my eyes open
and his german man's penis
now though he's going to be shocked to
see this
well for everything else gamescom 2017.
done videos
like this and actual content you could
go to our facebook
or our youtube we'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
bye